imagination has the ability to take you
from the world that you live in
to the world that you could live in we
have a vision
and what a vision is is the ability to
see that which cannot be seen that's why
we call it vision
we control who we are by what we think
about
i come from where you come from i've
been there i've done that
it wasn't easy for me to get to where i
am right now i use
two things and two things only ain't
nobody give me no money to get out the
hood then nobody give me no resources to
get out of that abandoned building
i use two things and two things only one
my mind
i envision myself getting out and to my
heart
and you can't measure that that's right
and you can't measure that so listen to
me i'm not about to tell you you can
quit
i'm not about to tell you that you're
going to keep that cycle going i'm going
to tell you to break that cycle
so listen to me you can get in a
different circle of influence you can
you can't get to another level but it's
going to take two things are you hear me
i got him from my mind
and i envisioned it i saw myself when i
was still
homeless when i was still a high school
dropout when i was sleeping in abandoned
buildings and eating out trash can
i saw myself one day being where i am
right now i don't care where you are
use what you got to get what you want
use your mind
use your vision use your dream i dreamed
my way out the hood
i dreamed my way out and then i saw it
and then i would get up every day and i
would grind hard
i would grind my way through it so
listen to me i'm gonna tell you a story
first gig i ever did in my life was
bermuda listen to me i dreamed about
bermuda for eight months before i got
there
i'm not playing with you i can't make
this stuff up or you hear me i went to
the library and i read about it
i asked my friends that were from
bermuda apartment and they told me about
the water
and they told me about the palm trees
and they told me about the island
are you listening what i'm telling you i
dreamed it eight six eight months i
dreamed it
i thought about it i read about it
listen to me from where i was
are you hearing me from where i was in
college not doing well
from where i was i dreamed it not from
bermuda i didn't dream it from bermuda i
dreamed it from where i was
in the library in my house walking up
and down that street thinking about it
and on everything i love i can't explain
it to you
but the james family the husband and
wife knocked on my small apartment door
one day with me and my wife sitting
there and they walked in with two
plane tickets two plane tickets to
bermuda are you hearing me
in a two-week itinerary of every church
and every school
and every youth detention center that i
was going to speak at and listen to me
it went from a dream i'll never forget
when i got my passport
i'll never forget when i landed on the
island of bermuda and said to myself how
in the world
and god said it was your mind as a man
think of so as he
think your way out of it grind your way
out
and i got up every day after i dream
about bermuda and i went to that ged
class and i put in work
i went in and i read to them and i spoke
to them and i inspired them and i
motivated them
so i leave you with this listen to me
change your circle of influence
change your circle of influence change
your life
no they may not give it to you but what
you want me to do
you want me to tell you it's okay to
quit you want me to tell you it's okay
to surrender
they may not give it to you nobody might
take you by the hand
and take you there you might not get a
mentor i don't know
but what i'm telling you is i did it
with my mind and my heart
and if i can do it start it from the
bottom now we
here started from the bottom i started
with my mind
i started with my heart you got a mind
you got a heart
stop making excuses stop waiting for
somebody to feel
sorry for you and to my teachers out
there and to my mentors out there
stop giving them a pass to quit yes it's
going to be hard
yes it's going to be difficult but you
can do it
as oprah winfrey said what you dwell on
is what you become
once you understand that humans are the
ultimate adaptation machine and you
understand that the brain
actually builds faster and better
connections between the things you think
on you will begin to understand
that it is incredibly important
to be thoughtful about what you think
about it's incredibly important to
pick a direction that you want to grow
in to decide
who you want to become and then make
that the center of your focus your
thoughts your time your energy
and if you look inward or if you look
outward and you don't like what you see
remember what jim rohn said if you don't
like how things are
change it you're not a tree and that's
the beauty
that's the beautiful thing about being a
human we are so plastic and we can
change so
dramatically we are so good at adapting
that we forget that's literally what we
do
but if you can take control of that
process if you can grab a hold of it and
make it your own
if you can make it your daily obsession
to make the most of your potential to
pick
a very specific direction to pick an end
goal an
end state and end identity and work your
way backwards find out the steps that
you're going to need to take to get
there to execute and have
the willingness to put in the work to
have the willingness to be both the
sculptor
and the clay to understand that the
suffering that comes with that of
changing yourself of making yourself
into something great
is a suffering well worth it it's a
suffering
that you should embrace it's a suffering
that you should run towards because
in that suffering you can become any
thing you want so
start to dwell on that dwell on a vision
of
you being great dwell on a vision of you
accomplishing your goals
dwell on a vision of you having done
this amazing thing that you want to do
dwell on an image of you being willing
to sweat and bend yourself in half
and break if need to and bleed when
necessary to become
the vision of yourself you always knew
you could become
dwell on that and nothing can stop you
most people never take the time to take
an inventory
about their thoughts yet our thoughts
control our world our thoughts are like
magnets they literally
draw towards us that's what we obsess
about
and so most people never take the time
to analyze what they think about
the most successful people i know are
the most self-aware
meaning they're aware of what they do
and they're also aware of what they
think they're aware of how they're
perceived
so today's message is about thinking
there's some stats you need to know
number one is
average person you and i have about 75
000 thoughts a day
rattling around in this thing we call
our brains and our minds 75 000 of them
the crazy thing is 91 of those thoughts
are identical to the previous day and
are identical to the day before that and
the day before that and the day before
that
and then we wonder why our life seems to
repeat itself over and over again so
really the difference in our life if we
have 75 000 thoughts a day here's the
crazy thing
91 of them are exactly the same the
separation in our life is in those nine
percent of their thoughts because
remember this
these magnets are pretty powerful that's
why i'm always saying that your
obsessions become your possessions
because they do
you draw into your life exactly what it
is you think about
it's a physical reality that you attract
to yourself what you think about
so the difference in our life is nine
percent of our thoughts
that's why people say all the time the
difference between winning and losing is
so small
it's almost too scary to talk about and
really we've identified what it is it's
nine percent of what we think about
alters the direction of our life so what
i'm here to tell you today is
you've got to hone in and get aware of
what you think about
and then alter those nine percent of the
thoughts that are variable on a daily
basis
to serve you because if you don't these
thoughts become like viruses they're
viruses in our minds
what happens in a computer when it gets
a virus it slows down it becomes
sluggish it doesn't function at its
optimal level
same thing with our thinking if we don't
get those nine percent of our thoughts
to serve us
our lives go in a completely different
direction so remember this
you don't see things in your life as
they are you see things in life as you
are
and so the more you alter you the more
you begin to see things differently
which is amazing
about this is we control who we are by
what we think about
think about this just for a second
wherever you're sitting watching this
the chair that you're sitting in
if you're sitting in a chair if you're
driving in a car and you're listening to
this
that seat you're in started in someone's
mind as a thought
right every detailer with the fabric the
cushions the way it's structured every
single piece of that
started in someone's mind as a thought
and then became a reality by putting out
the pieces together
see everything in life is that way as
well it always begins with a thought
when we think a new thought
here's what literally happens thinking a
new thought literally
opens a space up in our minds in our
lives
that never existed before prior to
having that thought
it's like a brand new space you've
created just by thinking it and what
happens is
your unconscious and subconscious mind
goes to work on filling in that space
with the people places resources and
things to fill it up like a room and an
architect would
to fill up that space and fully furnish
it that's the power
of how we think so literally everything
that exists started as a thought in
someone's mind and then became a
material matter
and so you've got to begin to think
about the things you want to materialize
in your life on a regular basis and
think about it repetitiously
literally the things that we obsess
about become the things that we possess
in our lives
most people those variable nine percent
of their thoughts is the new thing
they're worried about the new fear they
have
the new response to an email they have
to make and they never dictate the terms
remember this your mind is a weapon
and you got to begin to use it and pick
that weapon up and control it
most people are out of control with
their mind they don't point it at
something
they let the world point it and they
miss fire all the time
imagination has no fences to it has no
boundaries
it's it's more than what other people
maybe see for your life
i think imagination is the
cousin the creativity and i think
people that allow their imagination to
go beyond what is expected
began to find out very quickly that they
began to see things experience things
that they never would have before
to be honest with you if there's a fence
i'm always the kid who jumped over the
fence to see what was over on the other
side of the fence
imagination feeds off of the fact
that there's always an answer that
there's always a better way
that's usually there are more than one
answer so imagination
feeds that creative mind which allows
you to see
do feel think experience things
that you would never do at any other
time imagination has the ability
to take you from the world that you live
in to the world that you
could live in only by imagination
can some things be accomplished i do
hope
that you'll just kind of today let your
imagination go a little wild
one of the best ways to increase your
value
and your worth and your esteem as an
individual
is to have your own dreams dreams that
are born
in the womb of your mind dreams that are
born in the field of your heart
have your own dreams and make sure that
your dream is a musical
or a comedy it doesn't have to be high
drama or a horror show
have your own dream where you can see
yourself
doing exactly what you want to do
without
explanation or defense so very often
we live and become what mama wanted or
what daddy wanted or what mama wasn't
or what daddy wasn't have your own dream
see it first with your eyes closed
in your mind if you have to talk about
it talk about it
and then as you talk about it and you
see it start to feel it
and make sure it's in color make sure it
gets you excited
your dream is a new vision for yourself
that'll take you beyond where you are
and you don't need anybody else's
permission
to make it as grand and as big
and as glorious and as fun and as
easy as you want it to be a well
established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to
as a culprit if you organize
your mind to a certain level of
organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything is organized in the direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in one direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want
if you organize these four dimensions
in one direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction
the question of you reaching the
destination
is very remote unless it happens by
chance
so organizing our minds
and in turn organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now
in one direction if you do this you are
a kalpa ruksha yourself
anything that you wish will happen but
right now
if you look at your lives everything
that you have wished for till now
if it happens you are finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today
could you live with that once we're
empowered like this it's very important
that our physical action emotional
action
mental action and energy actions are
controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive
right now that is our problem the
technology
which is supposed to make our life
beautiful and easy
has become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis
of our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible levels of
comfort and convenience to us
in the last 100 years or so
has also become a threat to our life
simply because
we are not conscious action we are in a
compulsive state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means
moving from a compulsive state of
activity
to a conscious state of activity
you might have heard of people for whom
they asked for something and beyond all
expectations it came true to
true for them generally this happens to
people who are in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh i want to build
a house to build a house i need 50 lakhs
but i have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible
you are also saying i don't want it so
on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something
on another level you're saying i don't
want it so in this conflict it may not
happen
someone who has some faith in a god or
in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded faith works
only for those people who are
simple-minded
thinking people people who are too much
thinking for them it never works
a child like person who has a simple
faith
in his god or his temple or whatever he
goes to the temple
and says shiva i want a house i don't
know how
you must make it for me now in his mind
there are no negative thoughts
will it happen will it not happen is it
possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple act of faith
now he believes shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is shiva going to come and build your
house no i want you to understand
god will not lift his little finger for
you what you refer to as god
is the source of creation as a creator
he has done a phenomenal job there's no
question about it
could you think of a better creation
than this is it
in anybody's imagination to think
anything better
than what is there right now so as a
creator
he has done his job wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now
the very crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy the only and
only reason why you're unhappy is
life is not happening the way you think
it should happen
that's all it is so if life is not
happening the way you think it is
it should happen you're unhappy if life
happens the way you think it should
happen you are happy
it's as simple as that so if life has to
happen the way you think it should
happen
first of all how you think
with how much focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there
in the thought process will determine
whether your thought will become a
reality
or is it just an empty thought or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought
by creating negative thought process
this possible
is something possible or not possible
he's destroying humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's nature's business
your business is just to strive for what
you want
we have a vision and what a vision is is
the ability to see
that which cannot be seen that's why we
call it vision it
literally lives in my our imagination i
say imagine a world
imagine close your eyes imagine a world
in which the vast majority of people
wake up
every single morning inspired feel safe
at work and return home fulfilled at the
end of the day
and what you see in your mind's eye is
yourself and the people you love having
that experience and those feelings
that is a complete figment of your
imagination it is
not real it is the equivalent of an
iceberg
that's what vision is it's being able to
see that which no one else can see
because it lies beneath
and when we work with a small group of
people who say i believe what you
believe
and we will work together and what ends
up happening is a tiny little piece of
iceberg pops up
and a couple people go oh
that's what you mean yeah
i'm in and they join in and a little
more iceberg shows up and a little more
iceberg shows up
and before you know it everybody goes
it's amazing what you're doing
and you'll say tip of the iceberg
and the iceberg is huge and people say
look at all the success you've had
and you'll say tip of the iceberg
because that's what it means to wake up
every single day to advance
a cause it means that we devote our
lives
to building what which that which has
not been built
to advancing what has not been advanced
so showing that which is not seen
and not obsessing with the excesses the
successes we've had and how much iceberg
is above the ocean but how much more
work we have to do
and it all started with a tiny little
bit of ice sticking above the ocean
in there he says the imagination is the
most marvelous
miraculous inconceivably powerful force
the world has ever known
now the imagination is the mental
faculty out of which
visions arise
visions pictures that we build in our
mind
most people don't use their imagination
constructively
most people use their imagination
destructively they imagine what they
don't want
we've got to consciously and
deliberately imagine what we do want
if we will take and sit down with a pen
and ask ourself what do i really want
what do i really want and write it down
and then make a written description of
it
in the present tense writing causes
thinking
thinking creates an image and you get
these images going you're building a
vision
in your mind
it's the visionaries that's changed the
world
think of that the fact that i can sit
and look into this camera
and you can sit and look at me on your
phone
or on your tv or on your laptop
that was the result of somebody's vision
do you know everything you've got the
clothes you wear the house you live in
this microphone that's in front of me it
was all the result of somebody's vision
it's not an accident you and i have a
marvelous imagination
and everything starts with a vision
van gogh was asked how he did such
beautiful work he said first i dream my
painting
and then i paint my dream
what do you want to do in your life
where do you want to go what do you want
to make happen
what do you want to make happen for
between now and the end of the year
think about it for a moment don't think
of why you can't doesn't matter how much
money you've got it doesn't matter how
much help you've got
build a vision of what you would like to
accomplish between now and the end of
the year
and then make a written description of
that vision
paint the picture with words you can
rather away with this you can start
writing the picture and it'll come on
the screen of your mind or build a
picture and then paint it with words
[Music]
vision vision is going to direct
your life if you let it
use it constructively see what you want
don't spend any time thinking of what
you don't want
when you get a picture in here make it
big make it beautiful
you'll be glad you did the names of the
people who imagined the impossible or
engraved in our history by breaking the
limits of their imagination
by breaking their limits of their
imagination they change
they change the world you take cv raman
you take
newton you take einstein you take
chandrasekhar
there by breaking the limits of their
imagine imagination they change the
world
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i wanna know what was your
single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
percent
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you most people don't
concentrate long enough on achieving
their goals
so what happens you don't achieve your
goals if you're focused on something and
you do it
every day consistently you will
eventually get results
but if you're constantly jumping from
one thing to another from one
idea to another from one activity to
another
then you'll never actually accomplish
what you're capable of the problem isn't
lack of creativity or ideas or genius
it's a lack of concentration and if
that's you
i want to fix it in this video today so
let's take a quick look at my youtube
journey i started on youtube over 10
years ago it's crazy
it's been that long and i wasn't very
good when i started
go back and watch my first videos
they're all still up there i haven't
deleted them you can go back and watch
every single one of them see
how much i sucked i'm an introvert this
is not natural for me it took a lot of
concentration a lot of focused effort
and six thousand plus videos later here
i am why because i just kept going
because i kept focused on my mission of
my objective it took me 350 videos until
i wasn't completely embarrassed by
myself
350 videos i had to have my sister come
come to the room with the camera focus
on me press record and then leave
because i couldn't
film with her in the room and that's my
sister how is this guy going to be a
youtuber and be on stage and give
speeches and
be a thought leader and deliver
presentations if you can't even
do a simple video with your sister in
the room concentration
focused effort that's the key it's been
every single day we've been uploading
videos
we've done three plus videos a day for
the past five years
every single day i've been sick videos
went up i broke my neck in two spots had
a concussion
videos going up i lost my voice video is
going up all the time
every single day for the past five plus
years it's been at least three videos
across my main channel now my multiple
channels
concentration i'm not very good at this
the point of all this isn't to brag or
say look at me
it's saying that i suck that if i could
do it so can you
the difference is i think a lot of you
guys are way more talented than i am i
look at alex for example who works for
me at tds
he's just so much more naturally gifted
in front of the camera he's funny he's
charismatic
a lot of stuff that i'm not and i've
been slowly
grinding away getting better in front of
the camera so i think a lot of you guys
are actually better than me
or better than what i was and if if you
just kept going if you just kept working
on it
you would you would improve and you
would have the results you're after
you're just not
patient enough you're not concentrating
enough you're not putting in the work
every single day
this great story comes to mind that it
is great and sad at the same time i was
meeting a friend in
orlando another influencer uh
six years ago or so and we met up
and he said i'm gonna be the next gary
vee
okay great i love it pumped like let's
go i'm i'm just starting my youtube
career
really starting to take off and he's
wants to be his thing and he's going to
be the next influencer i love it
and then he posted something about a
year ago or so and he said
you know five years ago i met evan at
this place in starbucks in orlando and i
told him i was gonna be the next garyvee
and he was on his career to build his
youtube channel
and fast forward now and evan's got you
know a million million and a half
subscribers
and i'm still kind of where i was
because i didn't put in the work
and so that's what i don't want for you
right he just he has talent he's a
genius so are you
he just didn't do the five years of work
that i did
and he's someone who's actually i think
way more charismatic than i am and so i
don't want that for you i want you to
concentrate on your effort which will
then lead to results
and i'll give you a three-step process
that you can follow to help you get
there
step number one is flip patients and in
patients people have this really messed
up
view on patients and inpatients i think
people are often impatient with the
results
so you want the results immediately the
human nature you want it immediately
but you're very patient with yourself if
you look at what you're doing every day
like i'll do that tomorrow you get an
idea
yeah i'll start monday i'll start next
week i'll start i'll start next year
fresh years start off fresh all that
right no you flip it
you flip it you flip patience and
impatience what i want you to do is have
patience with the results
that the results will come and
impatience with yourself
that today matters today you're watching
this i don't know what time it is during
the day you're watching this
today matters what you create today has
to mean something
because if you approached every day with
massive impatience for yourself
and your effort and you did that every
day you did the work
that you were proud of yourself for your
effort i promise you that the results
are going to come
but it will take some time to get to
your big goals
you have big goals right you want to you
want to do something big you have big
ambitions you don't want just some tiny
little wind
awesome that's going to take some time
even if you're hustling and grinding
and being proud of your effort every
single day it's going to take some time
so patience with the results
and massive impatience with yourself
number two is think big and act small
this is where i think a lot of
entrepreneurs get tripped up you need to
think big
and act small so you have a big vision a
big mission something that you want to
go off and change the world my
big thinking is i want to solve the
world's biggest problem right it's
never going to happen in my lifetime and
yet i wake up every day trying to tackle
it
you want to have a big vision the
problem with it though for some people
is that
it means you don't start because to make
that big vision happen you need
money you need investors you need camera
gear you need equipment you need a team
you need all this stuff right just keeps
adding up all the stuff you need and
then you never start
that's the problem the reason why some
dummies are winning off of your idea
instead of you
is because they just started because
they acted small
so you think big and that's the
motivating dream that you're chasing
down every day
and you act small what's the smallest
thing that i can do today
just to start building momentum because
momentum is the thing that is missing in
most businesses
you have great ideas you're genius
you're talented i love what you're
trying to do it's amazing
you need momentum momentum every single
day
creating a little bit more momentum to
make that dream come true
think big act small and number three is
schedule for success
look at your calendar success is your
habits right you want to make sure that
your actions
map to your ambitions the actions that
are in your calendar if you did those
things would help you accomplish your
goals your dreams your ambitions
so if you're talking about building a
youtube career amazing show me in your
calendar where every week you're making
time
to make youtube videos if you want to be
an author awesome
i'm pumped show me in your time show me
your calendar where you've blocked it
out that you're going to spend time
writing on your book
most people don't do it and then you
allow all these little things these
distractions to pull you away from the
thing that you want to be doing
you have to put the big things into your
calendar first and block off the time
and protect that time and look at it
from above and not just
your business your your personal stuff
too what's a good relationship look like
what's a good health situation for
yourself look like right habits
put in your calendar and then step above
it and look at the week that you're
about to go off and do
look at your week ahead if you did those
things consistently would it help you
accomplish your goals
and for too many people it's no you're
living in reaction mode to other
people's emergencies and then you never
get to do the thing that you want to do
you got to defend your time you schedule
for success so whatever your big goals
are whatever you need to concentrate on
you need to make sure you're spending an
appropriate amount of time on it so that
you get good at it so you can start
getting results and making the impact
that you know you can make
thomas alva edison once made a very nice
statement
he said genius is
one percent inspiration and 99
perspiration we may have an inspiration
in our heart but one percent strong
burning inferno of an inspiration but
unless that inspiration is put into
action
dedicated committed hard work that 99
perspiration we are not going to be able
to achieve what we want to achieve
and so also when we talk about dealing
with our bad habits
success is one percent inspiration and
99
perspiration we need that inspiration
but
based on the foundation of that
inspiration we have to put in
dedicated committed hard work
that 99 perspiration
what's amazing is that 99
perspiration is based on the foundation
of that one percent inspiration if the
foundation of a building is
in place the very first thing that we
make when it comes to
building a structure a house a beautiful
edifice or a mansion
is we put the foundation in place if the
foundation is in place
if it's strong and robust then all the
building blocks
the bricks the cement the mortar the
steel can go on and form a
beautiful structure for us to
live in for us to dwell in and so also
that one percent inspiration is the
foundation
of that 99 percent perspiration
imagine if you're very inspired to
change if you're very inspired to give
up some of your bad habits
but you don't put that hard work that 99
perspiration
what good is that inspiration or imagine
if you keep putting 99 percent of
perspiration that hard work that effort
the dedicated commitment but if you
don't have that
inspiration to do it in the right
direction
and sustain it and get a higher shelf
life
what good is that hard work and
perspiration therefore success comes
by a balance of the two inspiration
which acts as the foundation and
perspiration which acts as the building
blocks
to build upon that foundation i once
read a very interesting
japanese proverb it said action
without vision is a nightmare
if you simply keep acting without having
the right vision
the result is a nightmare and it said
vision without action is a daydream
if you simply have a vision and you
don't act upon it
all you have as a result is a daydream
i have rephrased it for our discussion
here today
perspiration without inspiration
is a nightmare but inspiration
without perspiration is a daydream i
think
you know if we everything starts with a
thought i mean everything that you do in
your life
you you have to have a thought before
you initiate an action right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like
any great leader in history understands
that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so
give you an example most people wake up
in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those
problems are connected to certain people
and things at certain times and places
and the moment they start start turning
on those circuits
those memories are actually causing them
to think
in the past every single one of those
memories has an emotion associated with
them and emotions are the end product of
past experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the
they recall some problem in their life
they start feeling unhappy they start
feeling discouraged they start feeling
anxious
now thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how you think and how you
feel creates your state of being so we
could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past
well if you live in the familiar past
then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future
so what happens for most people is they
get stuck in their biology so think
about this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion
and an emotion that you can create by
thought alone so if you're living by the
same emotion every single day and those
emotions are influencing your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking
you're thinking in the past your lens of
the future
is going to be colored by the past so
you can't see possibilities so
most people like to wait for crisis or
disease or diagnosis before they wake up
enough to see well the challenge is is
that biology tends to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts begin to fire certain
circuits in your brain
the nerve cells that fire together wire
together so all of a sudden you start
getting hardwired
and those are the thoughts that you can
think the easiest at the same time
those thoughts produce chemicals called
emotions and the next thing you know
your body gets accustomed to living by
the same emotions and it could be guilt
it could be unhappiness it could be pain
but at least it's familiar to you at
least you can predict it so
some people would rather cling to the
familiar than take a chance and
possibilities so
for most people then they say well i
don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so
the first step to change is starting to
think about what you've been thinking
about
and change it and and then when you
begin to observe those thoughts you're
no longer the program you're the
consciousness observing just simply by
being an observer of your thoughts right
so
so though so most people though when
they when you do that when you decide to
really take a look it's like lighting a
match in a dark place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well
when you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown then it begs
the question what thoughts do you want
to fire and wire in your brain
because your attention on those thoughts
begins to
reorganize circuitry re-mold the brain
when you're at the major labels
you end up shooting a bunch of videos
that has nothing to do with what you see
for your song
you end up wearing clothes that you
don't see yourself wearing
while you're on red carpets and doing
events and videos you end up singing and
working with a bunch of producers you
don't want to work with
you get vulnerable because they're the
ones cutting the checks and if you
disobey then they may decide i'm not
paying for anything
that you're excited about you're gonna
do what i want so
going as far as i did i mean everything
for me down to the
album packaging like my album packaging
would look different if i was at a label
because everything is about the opinion
there is no opinion it's my opinion
it's it's visions that god sent me and
i'm obedient to the vision and i play no
games
i will run you over if you get in the
way people are successful have
extraordinary
imaginative vision and elon musk calls
it
a more complicated term which is arguing
from first
cause is not analogy so here's what
arguing from analogy
or not having extraordinary imagined
division let's say you're in a horrible
place
you were sleeping in your car yeah i was
sleeping on a couch
someone born in ghetto someone born in
poor part of india if you argue from
um uh a na i'm sorry arguing from
analogy means
well everybody around me is doing bad
i'm doing bad
therefore i'm gonna always do bad
that's arguing from analogy and that's
not having
imaginative vision the people who make
it
are the people who do the opposite they
go i'm gonna argue from first causes i'm
gonna say
has anybody ever written a written uh
risen up
from the ashes out of the ghetto or from
the couch or from the car
the answer is we all know that story so
if somebody else did it
then if you use extraordinary creative
imagination then why can't you do it too
and that's arguing from first causes
that's what allowed elon musk to make
tesla
spaceships solar city so for all of us
we get stuck
when we argue from analogy well
you know last time i started a business
it failed
last time i trusted somebody they
betrayed me well that's good that's
arguing from analogy that's just saying
because it happened before it's gonna
happen
it doesn't always work that way all of
us have a mind
it's the most powerful tool in the world
built a smartphone it's put
machines that drive itself on mars yet
there's no manual for the mine
right when was the last time you saw a
manual for the mind
yet you you buy a point-and-shoot camera
whose only purpose
and duty is to point and shoot it comes
with a 100-page manual
right yet we have the most complex tool
in the world are mine
and there's no manual so the first thing
i learned when i went to the monastery
was to learn
how the mind works because once you know
how the mind works
you can control it and once you can
control it you can focus it
you can't focus or concentrate something
you don't understand
most people have goals in life and we
would think you got to be goal-oriented
that's
the first mistake yes you need goals but
there's something far
beyond goals which is what all
successful people have
and that's a vision it's a vision for
the future see but here's it is you see
things as they are
but not worse than they are yeah which
is what a lot of people do
yeah they say oh it's so terrible they
tell themselves this wild story about
why they can't take action and in truth
the story they tell themselves
is exactly what holds them back from
being successful okay it's that [ __ ]
story that stops it from acting like
and then oh there's some of the economy
and they play the blame game they
complain they justify and it stops them
from moving forward so
see things as they are not worse than
they are yeah and then see them better
than they are
yeah and make them that way look at a
gandhi
right he survived hunger strikes and
united a country not because he had a
goal for a free india he had a vision of
a free india
nelson mandela all those years in jail a
vision yeah it's richard branson who's a
friend of mine who i know he sponsors me
my my speaking tour he's a visionary
bill gates they're all visionaries
and the best example considering
hollywood is a guy like james cameron
now here's the trap
james cameron is probably the greatest
visionary of all time in filmmaking
would you agree yeah
he was interviewed on um diane sawyer
and they asked him a question of
what do you owe your success to and what
he said was this i set
really really high goals so even if i
fall
short i'm still doing great and people
thought that was pretty profound i
actually believed that too
it's not true though see what's
happening is this james cameron
is not a goal setter he's a visionary he
just doesn't realize because he's
running an unconscious strategy himself
if you said the device that james
cameron was really just the goals of
your vision for avatar he'd say oh of
course i will
get all excited me tell you how nothing
was going to stop him from making this
movie
the fact that it took 10 years and ran
200 million of a budget and he put money
in himself all
that's not what goal setters do goal
setters will set a goal
gets tough and they abandon it and i
can't over emphasize that distinction
that's number one is vision there are
things within us that we have no idea
that are even there
because we've been indoctrinated by the
society in which we
are living a high-tech low-touch society
consumerism materialism
fear doubt worry and so
we visualize what we think we want to be
happy nothing wrong with that
but beyond that there's a gift a talent
a capacity within us all
that's trying to emerge robert browning
indicated
you know there's an inner splendor you
know that's trying to escape
so the visioning process invites the
inner splendor to come up
that may shock our surface mind
it may it may surprise us as to what's
trying to emerge
and what we must become and now
outside of our present paradigm
there the miraculous is there it's
something trying to happen through us
and we keep growing and growing so
visualization
is a stage of our spiritual growth it
teaches us there's a law in the universe
teaches us the friendliness of the
universe it teaches us that our thoughts
transmute themselves into things it
teaches us
that things don't just happen they
happen just
it's a good teaching stage but then once
we become comfortable and realize that
the universe is friendly
we can begin to give up control and ask
a higher question
and now we lose control we move into
surrender
that's that's that's the big game one of
the
um i guess most unbelievable discoveries
of the last hundred years is that our
brain can create
new neural connections new beliefs new
habits new perceptions
new neural muscles and reinforced neural
muscles
and so if you look at the problems she
says with curiosity
and with this approach she says a lot of
people
focus on debt and they go oh my god look
at the debt i'm in
how am i going to get out here's the
problem i can't pay this i can't do this
she goes now when you sit down and you
look at the debt
and you write down you brainstorm how to
get
out of debt and make more wealth
and write down every idea that you can
come up with
she goes you activate the creativity
neural muscle and the more you practice
it
the more you teach yourself how to focus
on
the solution instead of the problem
the more you're flipping your
neuroplasticity switch but the more
you're flipping on your curiosity
imagination and creativity circuits
imagination is more powerful than
knowledge when dealing with your own
mind
and the mind of others if i said to any
of you come and stand on this [ __ ] who
would come and stand on this chair
i'll give you a hundred dollars to stand
on this chair sure if i said well now
the chair
is that's is on top of that spire on the
highest building in tallinn
who's going to climb up and stand on it
for a hundred dollars who would do that
some people would because they've got a
good imagination if i can stand on it
there
i can send most people go no i could
fall you've got a little tiny plank up
here you can walk the plank when it's on
the floor
put the plank between two high-rise
buildings who's going to walk it
not many people because the imagination
that you could fall
and kill yourself is way more powerful
than the knowledge that i did this on
the ground
it's wide enough fear of flying
knowledge says it's actually the safest
place in the world the most dangerous
part of a flight is actually the drive
to the airport
that's way more dangerous than being in
the plane do you think the imagination
cares we're going in a flying coffin
i'm hurtling through the air and that
guy looks like he's come straight out of
isis
and he's in the bar i think he's going
to blow up the plane and then you feel
terrible the other person's going i'm
watching a movie i've always wanted to
watch the shape of water this is so
great
here's my time again to do nothing so
whatever you imagine would defeat logic
or defeat
knowledge and when dealing with children
people do logical
why are you so bad why can't you
get it what's going on why are you so
naughty and that doesn't work
i never say to kids why are you bad
again what happened to you
what habits allow you to consistently
come through in the clutch
and specifically when it matters most
just be calm
just be calm you know sometimes we tend
to over hype situations
you know kind of our imagination gets in
our own way yeah
you know and at the time you know brian
d wade a lot of those guys
especially brian was still young yeah
and hadn't really figured out those
pressure situations
and for me i was able to detach myself
from
it and uh and to allow
and uh to allow the work that i put in
that practice to manifest itself during
the game
right right so there's no need to panic
like i've taken these shots thousands
and thousands of times before
nothing changes yeah i've had games that
i've won
games that i've lost at the buzzer you
show up the next morning
and you get to practice again anyway
right right so
not getting in your own way imagination
is the real power imagine like
i imagined about the
app to transport me into your
side all the crazy things that you can
think about
when you imagine don't put in limit
be as wide as you can be in creating
the image of the world that you want to
create without any
hesitation without any limitation
be as wired as it can be in your
imagination
as if you are writing a social fiction
we write science fiction all the time
but unfortunately
we don't write social factions fictions
are the driving force
like in science in technology science
fiction becomes a driving force it makes
things happen
similarly if you have done the social
fiction it will make it happen
use active imagination
is deceptively simple
often what separates creative
from conventional thinkers is that they
simply
search wider they use their minds
to generate possibilities that others do
don't think of
then they work to verify what they came
up with
we saw a classic example of this with
pasteur
another great example is with henry ford
early on in his career in the earliest
years of what would later become the
ford
motor company ford
was anxious to inc to speed up
production of cars it was he he saw the
automobile
as the ultimate consumer product but in
order for it to become that
he had to greatly increase the
production rate in his factory
so he spent a couple days looking at his
employees on the factory floor
and trying to imagine how he could get
them to move faster
from car to car suddenly one day he
imagined something completely
different he imagined the men standing
still
and the cars coming to them he didn't
know what that really meant but he
decided to try it out and
lo and behold it increased productivity
by such an
incredible exponential rate that it
could now become
the consumer product that he envisioned
things like antibodies or assembly lines
they seem so
obvious to us now but they are never
obvious in the present and they involve
an incredible leap of what i call active
imagination
the difference between regular and
active imagination is that the latter
is used consciously to reach
very very practical results it's not
imagination for coming up with wild
things
it's imagination used for very practical
results
think of the active imagination as a
kind of creative muscle
that you're developing first
within the loose constraints of what
you're working on
you open your mind up to you give a
complete free
reign you entertain almost every
possibility
that you could imagine or visualize
you engage in what charles darwin calls
fool's
experiment fools experiments this is the
fun play part of serious play
you use notebooks sketches diagrams
models prototypes to help externalize
the products of your imagination
once you have gone through this you now
enter the second serious part
of the process first you choose
one or few of the more promising
possibilities that were generated by
your imagination
and now you actively work to test verify
or confirm it this might entail
launching a beta version on the public
once you have feedback you now go back
into the first part of the process in a
shortened form
using your imagination to perhaps take
what you have into an even better and
higher form
circling constantly through this process
in shorter and shorter cycles
until you've got something that's both
incredibly imaginative and incredibly
realistic
and practical by developing this by
going through this over and over and
over again
you will develop your imagination into
an incredibly powerful
creative muscle imagination is not only
the unique
human capacity to envision that which is
not
and therefore the fountain of all
invention and innovation
in its arguably most transformative and
revelatory capacity
it is the power that enables us to
empathize with humans
whose experiences we have never shared
great leaders envision a compelling
and different and vibrant future than
what is here
they have an alternative clear view of
what the world could be like tomorrow
than it is today right they have a
shared purpose
they believe that they and others would
be compelled by
interested inspired by and want to work
towards
and that's a big deal and you always
read about it in leadership right
you have to have vision i mean it's
biblical where there is no vision people
perish right we know the power of having
that vision so
you have to sit down though and actually
do it the reason we say
envision versus just have a vision is
you have to sit it's a it's a practice
of envisioning what should tomorrow look
like
for my team what should tomorrow be like
for my
business for my organization what should
tomorrow be like for my life
and not just tomorrow a long-term
mindset and view
the dream right that magnificent
obsession
that that bold desire the moonshot goals
and purposes and missions of life
the bigger picture that's envisioning a
different reality
in the future than we experience today
and that's what everybody gets excited
about in leadership
where there's no vision there's no
leadership where there's no vision
people
perish so you have to envision we always
have to continually sit down
and envision where are we where can we
be going it's an active process
if you set a vision one time and and you
forget about it it's not going to help
you
accomplish the influence or the impact
you want in your lifetime
or in those that you lead if you want to
know how you can become
what you imagine with earl nightingale
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you're worried about your
income or your future
you're concentrating on the wrong end of
the scale those who insist on remaining
spare gear must expect to be
jettisoned when things get too rough for
safety